what's going on guys
several months ago the people assembled
in this room gathered together to
foretell the future I'm talking about
predicting the summer box-office we were
all wrong but we're gonna find out who
is the least wrong and talk about the
summer numbers and the movies what we
like what we didn't like surprises hits
misses all that crap
let's see who's with us today first oh
you know her from clever movies you know
where you love her Aaron Robin and
undereating champion you all honey my
tea throw me today also here she is the
chief film critic of the LA Weekly Annie
Nicholson hello how and our old friend
he's member the family Dan Merle here
with two former champions or I former
and a reigning champion so yeah anyone
the first one Aaron one the last one
who's gonna win this one there were a
couple of big omissions from our lists
that no one picked that was kind of
surprising um
Mad Max fury road our good friend The
Rock's movie San Andreas and Straight
Outta Compton was not a none of those
were on anyone's list well we took so
much grief like in the comments was like
how could you not put fury road on your
list and I mean we all said it we
thought we were wanted to see it we
expected to see it I think what none of
us except ated was how good that movie
was gonna be it looks great but it was
so it was it exceeded everyone's
expectations yeah I actually thought it
was gonna be as good as it was my only
concern was the marketing they didn't
have a lot of marketing going in I
thought that not a lot of people would
go and see it but I really wanted it on
my top 10 I regret not putting it on
there now well I feel like every summer
there's a big temple movie that all of
the critics love and give rave reviews
to and nobody goes to go see it and that
just felt like the one it felt like it
was gonna collapse and now I feel guilty
for doom saying it before even giving it
a chance
a movie like that and also I was really
looking forward to Straight Outta
Compton but I think we were going with
our heads too much and not with our
hearts enough and that was one situation
Straight Outta Compton was not my radar
for the top ten it wasn't even I never
even considered it to be in the top ten
I didn't even occur to me how much free
promotion they would get from Dre and
cube going out and talking to everyone
San Andreas
raises me I didn't see anything that
distinguished it from any of the movies
that did lesser business and it just I
it's I think it's the rock it's got to
be the rock
I think the positioning of that kind of
helped it was kind of earlier in this
summer I think people were hungry for
blockbusters they were ready to go to
the movies I think that helped it a
little bit yeah it was just allowed to
snowball for a while Avengers age of
Ultron
we all had at number one it wasn't it
was number two made less than the first
Avengers Jurassic world number one
nobody saw that coming
what we miss you know it was a gamble
you have Jurassic world coming out in
Terminator you would have thought those
films would do about the same they're
resurrecting old franchises one of them
kills it the other one collapses and I
inequality was I think they're about the
same to really oh wow writing I'm no fan
of drastic world but Terminator Genisys
was the worst movie I've seen this year
so I mean I'll be the worst in Fantastic
Four uh-uh
yes really yeah I think I think that for
me Genesis was worse than fantastic Wow
okay get out of here I have like
visceral expressions what I think about
Fantastic Four's yeah I want to see the
movie about the making of that movie
because you know I would watch the first
hour and twenty minutes of it and I was
like I don't like what josh trank is
doing but it's an interesting take on it
mmm and then there's a literal
demarcation line where you can see the
studio took it over and then just became
super movie slapdash finished I almost
would have wanted to see the rest of
Josh Trank's failure than that slapdash
studio ending Josh Trank is gonna be
locked up like Howard Hughes in some
basement somewhere just editing his
version Ted - oh that was on my list
yeah I just didn't I couldn't get over
the visual of like the teddy bear with
the scene with the sperm I was just like
too much that's a shame I really like
him I like - Ted - I liked a million
ways to die in the West and I'll just
stay in my little bubble liking him and
hoping he gets to make more movies so as
I mentioned earlier age of Ultron did
worse than Avengers ant-man it made the
top 10 but it was no guardians are we
having some superhero fatigue are we
having some Marvel fatigue I think
there's a little bit of Marvel fatigue I
think word of mouth is so power
for right now with superhero movies and
I liked ant-man a lot I had a lot of fun
watching it yeah but there wasn't too
much to rave about when I left it wasn't
special it didn't feel like like
something I would tell people you have
to see this movie so I think that word
of mouth might have heard that a little
bit I actually enjoyed a man more than
Ultron I liked ant-man more than any
other Marvel film because to me the
problem with Avengers all age of Ultron
and with almost every other big movie we
saw this year is it always ends the same
with them saying we're going to destroy
the world in the next 20 minutes unless
you're never gonna destroy the world so
who cares yeah so I think that the
stakes have gotten too big and that's
why I loved ant-man it was small it was
perfect
Oh perfect female-driven movies so pitch
perfect was in the top 10 numbers 11 and
12 or spy and trainwreck how do we feel
about some of the female driven films
this summer I feel like the female
audience didn't have a lot of options
the summer and I think comedies are
always wonderful for female audiences I
didn't like pitch perfect one but I
loved pitch perfect 2 I thought it
brought it to a whole different level I
thought it was even funnier than the
first and it just goes to show that
women want to want to be satiated at the
box office - oh I thought one of the
weirdest like opening showdowns of the
entire summer was when Mad Max and pitch
perfect to open against each other and
all of a sudden pitch perfect 2 was the
big evil giant that was going to take
money out of the hands of Mad Max I mean
the argument might be made because it
was a sequel and people say you know
reboots and sequels put those kind of in
a class like the name recognition of the
franchise that's true sort of like Mad
Max um yeah but less recent yeah yeah
well what surprised me was that well Mad
Max was turned out to be and I love it
literally a female-driven movie furiosa
was as big a part of arguably bigger
there was literally a woman driver Lee a
woman driving at max fury road and then
the one it didn't do well was
Tomorrowland and one of the big reason
of the big reasons that I would
recommend Tomorrowland for people for
people to go see it's it's flawed but I
love the fact that the the the hero of
that movie was a young girl but she
didn't have to be young girl she wasn't
written that had that had to be young
but just as easily been a boy but it was
a girl and I like that
tomorrow and a lot too and uh not only
was the girl driving the story like an
awesome young chick but the badass
ass-kicking robot was also a young girl
you know it was just like two really
cool tough women saving the future yeah
I think most of us had Tomorrowland on
our lists and yeah that's another that's
another strike against what's the
biggest surprise let's go down the line
surprise for me was Mission Impossible I
am I didn't expect it to be as good as
it was yeah I didn't even put it on my
list in my top 10 um but it ended up
being one of my favorite movies I think
maybe of the year for me my surprise was
vacation okay cuz that'll forgot the
worst review some of the worst reviews
of the summer and I went and saw it at
the drive-in and had the absolute best
time and it wasn't just me like a lot of
times I feel like I'm alone and nobody
else thinks what I think is funny is
funny like Seth MacFarlane but in the
drive and you could hear everybody in
every car just cracking up for me the
biggest surprise was how few movies the
summer turned out to be out outstanding
fury road inside out I would definitely
say was an outstanding movie and when
you look at the summer lineup and you
see it's only two or three movies yeah
that really quality-wise stood out from
the pack that surprised me I thought we
might have four or five shall we get to
the list results everyone
dun-dun-dun starting with myself I had
six out of ten okay hey at least I'm
over the 500 mark my missus at
Terminator Genisys Tomorrowland Ted 2
and pixels oh I just thought how could
it be so terrible with Peter Dinklage in
it I thought the video game factor would
help it no Aaron Robinson also 6 out of
ah you're mrs. Fantastic Four Terminator
Genisys Magic Mike double XL and
tomorrow and I loved Magic Mike double
excel for the record amy Nicholson can
she take it for a second time six out of
ten you're mrs. spy which did well it's
so good
it was almost there it was very good
tattoo Terminator Genisys and Ricky and
the flash big dice roll on that one
I like Vegas you know that was my double
down Dan Merle seven out of ten ah Dan
Merle is our new box-office champion way
your missus tomorrowland Ted to Magic
Mike double XL yeah the one person to
exclude Arnold Schwarzenegger Terminator
Genisys from his top ten I am glad that
that can help me be a victory because
that was an atrocity to movies and to
humankind in general dan Congrats buddy
but now you're the movie fights champion
and our box-office predicting champion
geez
super you don't let it go to your head
all right we also asked you guys to put
your lists in the comment section of the
video and we would determine winners and
the winners will get screen junkies
t-shirts a lot of people beat the crap
out of us um several of you had eight
out of ten so we had to go down to some
tie breakers Congrats Dylan Lang car you
had eight out of ten and a couple the
movies in correct positions and Blake
Richie eight out of ten the only person
to see into the future and choose
Straight Outta Compton so Dylan Lang car
and blake richie check your youtube
inbox and or tweet at us at screen
junkies and we will get you your well
earned prices what's going to end the
year top of the box office
ah Star Wars Star Wars I'm gonna go
drastic world drastic world stars star
wars what do you think is gonna be the
biggest moneymaker of 2015 what's gonna
surprise on the fall let us know in the
comments section below best answer we're
gonna send you a screen junkies t-shirt
and Dillon and Blake you got screen
druggies t-shirts coming your way I want
to thank Erin Robinson Aimee Nicholson
Dan Murrow congrats buddy and I want to
thank you for watching
I'm how redneck hit me up on Twitter bye
bye it is kind of weird though that he
played a guy stranded on a planet in
interstellar and he's doing that in this
light interstellar or spoiler alert he
hasn't seen interstellar he plays a bad
astronaut yeah you know this one he
plays a good astronaut it does look and
feel like ever turn to form for the
skies